there they are that's Frank Kelly I know
adjusting his camera um and for those
who are watching right now on this
edited version of the Rich Eisen show on
Zoom this is take three the third take
of Joey Molinaro and Frank Kelly I know
trying to get this thing done because
Frank's phone is on the precipice of
what what is what is your phone resting
on right now my wife has a tail so she
actually is a tripod she's a little
shaky
okay very good and Joey you've just got
yourself a laptop showing off your your
undisclosed location mancave and your
new barstool that looks like that's
right yeah I'm good I went with the the
higher grade laptop here because I
didn't be the first guy the new guy
messes things up franksen bet so Frank
and you know he can do all this city all
he wants but so is that is that issued
straight from Portnoy
when you get hired is that part of like
the the hiring package that Joey the Hat
yeah actually so the CEO said to me
because in my video that you so kindly
were part of I had to just print off
this giant Barstow logo and tape it to
the front of the head and she was like
hey could have since she a real hat and
it's like yeah go ahead so they send me
a nice little care package alright and
Frank where's your head I have plenty of
them but uh you know I got I got one of
these right here little FFC a man ready
to go come on man he might be a bar
stool but I'm a bar counter man that is
a Gruden issued fired Football Coaches
Association that's what he's got going
on that's what he he goes backwards had
kind of guy now Gruden bruton did his
fired football coach's Association he
had his office next to a Publix in Tampa
you know that right you know yeah you
were you did you ever go to the FFC a
did you ever been by the FFC a at that
little
this little strip mall right off like
the freeway but then they did them they
rebuilt the the studio in Orlando at the
Disney complex thing just to make it
look exact an I say one thing I want to
go back for a second not to where I was
dropping the phone or just appreciating
you but I worked at Fox for nine years
and I was at ESPN four I'm not sure how
long I never got a hat a free hat from
anybody
so Joey are already knocking out of the
park
not just on social media but on headwear
oh yeah and by the way a shout-out to
them as well this laptop courtesy of
them so first week there I am what else
is in the room that's from borstal other
than you with a hat in the laptop Joey
that's about it I think I said I'm in my
Steelers mancave and rich I have a
little surprise for you here I don't
know if I want to throw it off this is
this is something that I just remembered
right before it came on I think all you
guys this is a Rich Eisen fully hair
rich look at that some buzzing stuff and
then I have that we don't just randomly
print off pictures of you rich don't
worry this is a autograph that I got
back I'm like what 2005 are you kidding
I'm nine it says to Joey and the you
signed it Rich Eisen we didn't actually
meet my dad's best friend was that I
think a Super Bowl event or something
okay you were there and he brought me
back I have like a Brady Quinn one I
have a Drew Brees one and then he
brought me back a photo of Rich Eisen
and so this was up in my basement and in
our mancave and here we are today so
we've come full-circle rich I don't mean
to interrupt Joey because that's really
great and there's no way to match Joey
on the internet because he's the most
unprecedented human being I've ever seen
on the Internet he's unbelievable he
lost but I have future what you're going
to look like in the future an autograph
from actually look like
there's Arnold and Willis yeah you
didn't know this but you're going to be
eventually adopting with your maid hold
that up hold it up one more time because
if we get the before in me later right
2005 breakage in 2045 rats right there I
gotta ask you know cuz it's my job to
ask follow-up questions Frank why do you
have a photograph of Conrad Bain Todd
bridges it's a great guy woman in your
in your office what do you have Frank
actually this is the podcast studio and
that's my podcast partner John Homburg
actually brought that as a present
because I had this which he found pretty
cool which is Mike Tyson's punch-out a
sign and there I am in future future
Frank Caliendo my god if you want
anything else here here's Brockman boo
boo I will take that Frank why they
ain't Sonia brown socks behind you man I
got a we got I just I've noticed those I
can't I can't do it I was wondering the
same thing is a huge Pittsburgh Steelers
guy so that's it's kind of a mock a mock
joke Oh three what man I had fair socks
from Antonio broke through they were
frozen solid man oh man Joey you run
into anybody yet that you've imitated
have you I'm not you've no man from
second be like for him do you think when
he gets that moment where you just
crosses paths with some buddies I think
it always depends on the person
that's there are certain people that
would not look me in the eye it's
incredible ridiculous that was no one's
saying names cuz that would be bad we
gonna let it out there will be horrible
it would be
there are people that as you know are
nice about it but don't always be you
know yeah I know then there's like
shefter who's like I know it you're I
know it but it doesn't sound like it to
me
but you can you can keep true minds
that's helium atom Schechter I think for
Joey I think it'll be I mean there's
this thing about a joy Molinaro that's I
don't know it's such a quick rise up
that people just want to jump on board I
say there's that there's that element
and I was actually reluctant right I
mean I talked to Joey a bunch of time
for him like ah I don't want to just you
know be a pig jumping on this thing and
we talked a bunch of times and then
found the the right thing to actually
work together on which was the Andrew
Luck a Bill Belichick bid and it's just
kind of it's just kind of fun but I'm
trying to think who are the people who
you haven't met Wars run yet no I've met
order on I'm friends with Nick Saban's
daughter okay actually that's the thing
it's the most Nick Saban thing ever
because I had her on my show and I asked
her and she was like I'm not really sure
and that's just so perfectly saving
because you know he's just like I don't
really I mean I don't have time for
Twitter okay football program their
props he came with his own props but no
I haven't met words right but the thing
is or John's on Twitter and all the
other tweets is hold that target but you
got to think that at some point he has
to have run that you know into something
so the Saban stuff man is what the first
time that I I you caught my eye view on
Twitter I because Brockman and I have
been all over the Saban press conference
with the coke-bottle and for
some reason I don't know what it is but
Alabama's podium Alabama football's
podium is the most sensitive microphone
anytime
side of the podium you're like a thought
right I mean like that's all he does
right because he talks so much with
everything I don't know how the
coke-bottle but just fall off the damn
white guy I mean it's all just I in the
hand motions like and I would bet rich I
would bet that that microphone is that
sensitive because he doesn't really
raised his voice ever when even when
Saban yells in those conference you know
he gets excited he's still almost in a
whisper yeah for sure
it's always just Stern it's never loud
it just gets more Stern as he be angry
or he gets all right I always say like
people who have asked I always say like
how am I getting a statement is just
imagine anything that like I had to go
to Jiffy Lube or something and they're
like yeah your car's gonna be fine but
we have to use this little tiny piece
it's like $350 and God do it today if
you want to make your car better so he's
just like I mean what are we gonna do I
don't want to come in here and spend
this kind of money this is where I wanna
be I do that that's fine okay my
favorite you know my favorite word Joey
knows my favorite Saban word oh it's
100% program program program the r OG
are you why is that your favorite word I
don't know it's just it's one of those
links you find those links and
impressions where if you if you watch
even the evolution of Joey doing the
Nick Saban impression it gets better and
better and better I mean the first one
is great but as you look at it now and
you go I mean that was for me 20 years
ago with a Madden or something any
almost say impress you do they they just
get better and better and better and
that's one of those words at the
beginning the first time I heard it I
was like oh that's good that's good and
it's you find that word everything and
that might not have been it for him you
can talk to that Joey but you find
a word or a phrase a ramp-up and then
the rest of it starts to flow and then
the rest of it becomes the same as those
phrases or that word and sometimes
they'll go off on their own tangents
when I was working on an ore shrine
which I kind of gave up on after seeing
Joey do it yeah just because it kind of
became his fit one of his things right
was every time we tried to do a doors
run like on the podcast or something it
became
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's the thing - Frank is that like
people will message behind as I'm sure
they do to you like people will message
me on Twitter or whatever and be like
you've got to do Trump you got to do
Cruden you got to do a gym room I'm like
Grune in Rome our Frank that's your
bread and butter like I'm not hopping on
those - you know yeah you try to give
that a little bit and Joey's really
great about that - which is another
thing I like so many people just steal
on the inert like they watch you do an
impression and then they copy it and
that's a real that's just what it is and
now people just show other people how to
do impressions on their tick-tock speeds
in between you know the trunk you know
it's so you're watching that you're
going well you're kind of unlocking it
for everybody and then it makes which is
fine but then everybody's doing it and
it's just kind of good you just kind of
go man there's nothing interesting about
this anymore in you you go away from
what's the word for Madden by the way
the Madden some are all stuff that you
have been doing from the good so friggin
funny including was getting his ass
cleaned up by a fire hydrant and used
the word bag literally had to stop what
I was doing I literally had to stop just
here on day that was the word that I
cheated on for men good day because you
know he's that you guys over in France
in those European countries this was
before the coronavirus think and
you know here 56 years ago we would get
it's like hey that's a nice toilet and
then so I don't like to do you always
have me do the mad and thing and stuff I
don't love you I somebody says do some
John man I was like I done it for so
long I don't really love doing it on
camera because it is so old right but
for some reason with the voiceovers I
was just like this is kind of like it's
whole its own thing and then he had Pat
Summerall along with John Madden John
everyday you bet I have John it's from
Madden 86 if I ever have ever told you
this story that CBS sports told me when
I took the job for the US Open did ever
tell that story Brockman knows it very
well
I know it's my favorite though when I
took I took a job doing the late-night
highlights show for the US Open after I
left SportsCenter and if L Network hired
me and then CBS called me when I was on
my honeymoon to see what I do the
late-night show that they they
shoehorned in in between Letterman and
Kilbourne to date this is the era okay
you get your story but first breaking
news I love myself back he's a mom smile
on Instagram by the way really yeah just
the most eccentric interesting Instagram
feed out ever agreed Joey we we we you
got a truck you got to check it out it's
mr. Craig Kilborn we had him on for a
full hour one back in September right
Chris yeah September yep gonna celebrate
the UH the ESPN anniversary that neither
of us were invited to celebrate I said I
don't want to be a party pooper but get
back to the story the story is this I
get the job and they tell me you know
the rules of doing tennis cuz a couple
of matches I was gonna call and they
said two things is shut up during the
action and read the card we give you
when
there's something for you to promote or
read for the sponsor on the air and I'm
like that's basic stuff they're like
trust me there's an issue sometimes and
I'm like with who and they said well
when summer all you said to do the
tennis remember it was patent used to do
US Open tennis hat they would hand him
the copy that you would read for the
Goodyear blimp you know hey and it's
50th year the Goodyear blimp is over
Manhattan and it's looks beautiful and
Goodyear you know the tire is the best
whatever it is and they're like supposed
to read it and I'm like he didn't do it
and they're like love sometimes Pat
would get lost and maybe you know I had
a little bit for that and so it would be
the shot of the New York skyline and he
has to read all the copy and all you
hear is Manhattan so I got to do my my
play-by-play they show they like okay
grab card 43 it's the Goodyear blimp
shot they show us shot of a skyline and
all I go is man screamed curse words in
my headset read the half a car used oh
my god there's my story Summerall is the
old-time greatest when it comes off well
that old bit was that he never and it
fits like that man had thing he didn't
speak in sentences yes it was just
phrases to the 20 to the 25
there's a man down and then he then he
would pronounce the comma and Murder She
Wrote by pausing a very long Murder She
Wrote last night before people now text
me or message me on Twitter and stuff
when there's an old NFL game on and it
was Madden Summerall doing Patriots Rams
and it was classic Pat Summerall because
younger people who hadn't really paid
attention to that that much we're
tweeting at me
and it was Warner Holt at about oh man
so Joey one of the things you did
recently that I loved and I retweeted it
wasn't really an imitation of a specific
person at all but uh you coming back
from a date and being interviewed in a
closet for a press conference where you
were just like that nonchalant
quarterback who says something without
saying anything was it any specific
quarterback you'd actually did have in
mind right there Joey where did that one
come from well my mom is a huge Eli
Manning fan and Eli Manning has always
been somebody to me who's been the king
of like you said saying something
without saying absolutely anything at
all in the most dull way possible I'd
like to think I was a little bit bit
cooler than Eli Manning maybe looked a
little bit better than him he's kind of
goofy and kind of that like just dead
face that he has on you know I mean so
just a little bit of that as an
inspiration but no I mean you guys know
just being in lock rooms all the time
and like you just have to sit there and
you know you have the people talk about
this a little bit and it's just okay all
of a sudden they're talking about how
the game playing didn't work but it did
work and we'll draw it up again next
week and you're like what am I gonna use
so that's really what it was just like
taken and real life obviously because
I've been around it so much in sports
and let's make these parallels happen it
worked the whole area so rich that even
though that's not a direct like
impression there Dana Carvey talks about
this too and he's explained it the best
that I've heard is that you do an
impression of a non famous person and
that's a character you do impression of
a famous person and that's an impression
now the big difference between those is
that you have to have a little more
setup for the character who's the non
famous impression Joey's really great at
that that immediately giving you the
point of view of the person so you go
okay I know exactly where
is going but you do I mean it's like
when you would watch Cheers back in the
day and you know cliff or Carla's gonna
say something and then they say it
you're like that's exactly what they're
supposed to say how did I not think of
that those are great moments and that's
one of the things when I talked to Joey
my grandson it's like three times a week
from Frank by the way that'll be like
how's the homework and it's just this
the next line that supposed to go to my
son would you I do actually
that happens because my son's Joey
Caliendo he's Joey Mullen Darrow and I
had to change him in my phone are you
dinner oh yeah I texted him a few times
with things because we're supposed to go
through my son he's like you beat you'll
add up there like where the hell are you
Frank that's because I was Belichick
Havok listen there's uh I have cameras
all over your apartment so all right
let's get into a couple here if you
don't mind winding it up and letting it
fly so what's your favorite imitation
you've been doing right now
lately Joey which one do you like to do
the most because I don't want to just
grab one that you're not is it is it
Andrew Luck is it the latest one I mean
I can I I always loved that what's it
just thing about I was thinking one that
I like to do too and it's one the Frank
obviously started it but then one that
I've piggybacked off and has actually
worked pretty well it's Mel Kiper
okay okay Frank does a lot but yeah I
mean with that those two obviously my
college coaches a lot like poking fun at
Cowherd with his analogies and
everything a lot I don't have a mess
with but I can kind of you know okay all
right so then choose which one you want
and then Frank if you want I don't know
is it okay more still I'd like the two
of you guys to go back and forth talking
about what show is your binging while
you're sheltering in place right now
okay if you want to just just choose
just go back and forth have a
conversation suggesting what the other
one should
that's basically there's a kind of who's
lining is this anyway so would you do
Morgan Freeman or is that one that
you're like screw it I don't to do any
math I don't I don't care sunny we can
pretty much do I'm probably bounced in
and out of five or six while we're doing
this maybe Tony Stark will show up that
happens you know let's go back and forth
here I've been binging hey let me ask
you this and I know this pretty good set
up right here
hey has anybody done a Joe exotic anyone
anyone out there anybody anybody tried
that so it's set out exotic it's just
the Oklahoma version of a Mike Gundy out
there that's pretty popular right now
and you look at you take Mike Gundy add
a little bit of sass to him then I've
suddenly got jokes are they talking
about his Tiger pups gonna watch
something pretty good I say you come
watch us on my farm okay now do me a
favor bring it down and it becomes
Edwards run down it bring it one thing
they'll simply do it like do the boss
it's a titles not only on the football
field without talk boys bring it up
jokes on it see I did I get a bit about
this today between who's gonna be the
tiger King whether it's gonna be
Coachella myself I've been doing this
for over 30 years I can say to myself
the true Tiger King but I can't tell you
the truth dr. King brings and bear rules
Louisiana which noburo myself don't find
us tell you what man both those guys are
exotic and I get the same eyebrows as
that guy Joe exotic here we go enter the
chat just spider 2 y banana day in and
day out I'll never forget spider 2 why
I'm teaching that to my daughter she can
already read of course because she's my
daughter and I went to Stanford new
character Joe neurotic that's what I'm
gonna do that Joe Nawrocki
cab right here and I I can't I was a
camera alright is everything okay Larry
the Cable Guy
that's all that's fine that works
I see how the Saint Antonio Brown sags
behind you good play I think he's got a
little bit of a few marbles loose up top
if I would say but I don't think this
should hurt him to come back per se he's
just kind of a wild guy I'll tell you
what Andrew he was great when we could
find him yeah it's kinda like God catch
me if you can
I've been watching that a lot big Leo
DiCaprio fan but you couldn't catch him
- well could you good night he could not
catch him
you could only hope to contain them I
said man I've heard about this better
call Saul you ever do that have you ever
watched better calls even better call
Saul that you are aren't you rich oh
don't raise sorry that wasn't set up for
you oh yeah no I caught up on that last
night just last night coach I caught up
on it's a slow burn though you know what
I mean it's I love it I just I walk
around being my Kermit job okay all
right everything is gonna be fine
don't worry we'll take care of it good
Frank was this Gustavo frame did he that
might be a little bit of a spoiler alert
man gotta clean the fryer though make
sure you clean the fryer man sweat it
out
oh it's coming back to me I was going in
to save man so I got the bottle of water
you should have seen it coming through
crowds amazing he's going into the same
Italian or screwed up he wasn't watching
the props get ready he's doing his own
thing so here we go okay
armentrout bobblehead man jeez what is
that fear in the collection
oh here we go throw it or let's throw it
over to Nick Saban what's making him
angry today well there's my anger
because I'm quarantine in my house I
can't run on my football program I'm
trying to win the national championship
yeah ed order on now here man doing his
media tour everybody's in love of that
order on what about uncle Nick alright
uncle Nick's been around for 10 plus
years I want a national championships
all the time I got a statue
I'll show statue for that man I ain't
got time for it so just quit ask him and
now I have to say with no further ado
prop to Steven a smurf this is
smurftastic what in smurfin tossed off a
ship has happened to the Rich Eisen show
today this zum-zum Smurf ERISA its
Steven a smurf everybody and I'm
completely not only perfectly deniable
in every single situation oh my god
so funny my wife who knows Steven a very
well just walked down the hallway she
just opened up the doors and what the
hell is going smooth years ago before
years ago there was a transition time
where Steve and I had left
[Music]
Espeon my jets my jets come pardon me
so think it was over he was over at Fox
remember he had that show that was
frankly speaking or something like that
and then it went away and he went over
to Fox Sports for a little bit when I
saw min and elevator Earth right an
elevator he goes do me a favor mr. Kali
and all the impressions in the First
Nations you do don't ever if I do me is
that really what happened yeah I mean
your semi joking but it was do me a
favor don't ever ever do me any it
somehow timed the elevator doors
there was another time that we're in LA
it was a Clippers game I took my son and
in the elevator Steve nay it was Steven
a incognito he's just kind of sitting
there with his head down a little bit
and he goes Frank it's like yeah Frank
what it's me I'm actually a spy in the
middle of a covert operation this is the
level I actually speak at and I'm
walking worried about Russians I'm
taking it over I'll make it all fun you
ever see the Americans that's me
never seeing the Americans on a big fan
of that one the more of a movie guy like
to go the movies can't do it right now
in the quarantine but wife and I do sit
down every night or up he'd stop maybe
put a local establishment bring in a
movie see that's my that's my kuipers
that it's not bad it's really good man
it's very does a tremendous job he
stresses movie I'm guy who stresses Todd
Mel and tell Piper hey that's my brother
Cal or or hell the guy who does all the
preview no he grades all the priests you
know that bit that I put out yeah Mellon
held Piper oh my god I think we're Chris
Brockman were what we're witnessing a
little workshopping between these guys
yeah I always wonder what the process is
for you guys like who's texting whom
who's coming up with the ideas is it
free-flowing but between us I mean we
kind of just throw things out to each
other I mean not not even I guess just
recently for some sketches and stuff but
we don't work on impressions together so
much John Homburg who do I do the
podcast with Caliendo cast we do that
constantly and go back and forth and we
had Kevin Pollak on a few weeks ago he's
amazing and Kevin Pollak talked about he
and Dana Carvey would do the same thing
so you go back and forth we said you got
to go rich because you got that I
appreciate you being on kind of look no
at the end are you kidding me it's the
greatest thing ever
no but yeah I think that's you in the
room that's all I think one of the
things Joe and I haven't really done
that kind of a thing
but it's sometimes you'll do that but
it's more we go back and forth I hate
what about this idea so we don't step on
each other a lot so that's kind of I
think more of the idea there yeah that's
how the kuiper thing was birthed because
I you know I knew it was gonna his I
message to a message Frank and on
Twitter and that's where he was like you
know a lot of people just do kind of one
that I do so send me your so I sent it
to him then we had a call and that's
where it kind of came up with the idea
of like okay you know like I said I kind
of focus more on like dragging out the
war whether movie or thing like that and
then you're just kind of yeah I said
basically don't do pod pod pod
that's because that's that's oh that's
like doing not get a day all right like
you can't own like you can't really own
an impression especially in this day and
age but what you can't what you don't
want somebody to do is take your version
of the character and that's the tough
thing because but you'll see people you
can tell when an impression is
quote-unquote stolen because they're
they're just doing yeah I had a guy go
before me on stage one time 20 years ago
and he started doing his John Madden bit
he started with here's a guy I'm like
that's that's my bit don't don't take
you know the actual bit that's the
that's the thing like and I come up I'm
more into these and it doesn't work as
well on the internet I found but a the
stuff that used to work on sketch TV
shows which wasn't so much the dead-on
impression or finding a little thing and
was finding a big thing and that doesn't
work as well in the Internet to me
people will be patient and find that
interesting moment or two that you find
in the impression if you're too big they
they don't like it as much and I'm
trying to think of one of the ones we
used at you you know Will Sasso used to
do it with Kenny Rogers they turned into
a complete character because it's will
to probably still work but those things
people get mad at me when I do mad
like that they like the one that sounds
like the exercise it's a weird a weird
thing that the smaller video people are
watching on these little handheld
devices as opposed to the bigger
medium-sized TVs and it's a different
way people look at stuff well let me
tell you this man this has been a total
blast and one way I guess Joey for you
to inoculate yourself for having bit
stolen is just create a smurf of that
character so if anybody bust up the
Smurfs they know
it's been totally stolen you know so we
suddenly Cowherd I'll work on that with
countered maybe we could help with
somebody for it but oh yeah follow Joey
Molinaro on twitter at Joey Molinaro at
Frank Caliendo this has been a blast
guys thanks to the laughs we needed it
appreciate it absolutely anything and
we'll be seeing you on barstool right
Joey we'll see you all right yeah I'm
fully there as you can see so I'm just
pumping out stuff there when I can and
working with Frank a little bit too and
check out the Caliendo cast as well
right Frank
correct yeah is there anything else you
want me to show and normally what I've
done with my guests to say show me
something from your office but you've
done quite a bit look at that one right
there that that's from Hard Knocks right
I have a couple of them rich they win
but uh this is this is this is actually
this is actually a real game November 19
1955 that's what I was hanging a clock
on my toilet I slipped hit my head and I
came up with this the flux capacitor man
knock on wood if you with me thank you
that's Frank Caliendo Jolie with
Molinaro here on the horizon show